Mi fai uno stacchetto di entrata Vai
Buonasera
Vai calcolato quanto tempo Bella a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
io sono Favij Oggi siamo con il buon
Dexter e abbiamo il buon Pietro
alberello l'unica persona che qua dentro
che ha un talento Ragazzi
[Musica]
ma oggi faremo un video un po'
particolare Allora vi ricordate il video
dove cercavamo un indovinare le canzoni
fatto con una persona che sta a suonare
ovvero Dexter che suonerà questo proprio
un musicista Grazie
vieni in Porta un piano lui ha portato
un piano e tra l'altro per portarlo qua
l'abbiamo caricato nel baule della
macchina nonostante tutto
C'è sempre da dire che gli ospiti nei
video di Favij vengono trattati per bene
Infatti stiamo andando in studio a
registrare Sei contento Pietro ok Siamo
siamo così andiamo a registrare andiamo
andiamo Chiudi chiudi chiudi Ciao ciao
ok mani dietro siete pronti siamo pronti
[Musica]
Allora no no no perché prima Inizio
trasmissione mi fa Oh Piano Questo è di
casa mia eh mi raccomando schiacciatelo
piano
Porca miseria Vabbè eh non è ti sei
prenotato quindi Bravo bravo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
è un cretino
[Musica]
Infatti è bello è bello quello
OMG in realtà volevo farti continuare
sinfonia numero 4 numero 27
26 2 99
[Musica]
Sì ma tu mi fai paura Bravo
Complimenti
però comunque cioè perché ti ho visto
che andavi Quindi eravamo già perso
dovevo fare qualcosa
non so
Winx
come faccio a saperlo Non lo so Non me
lo fa non fate domande ragazzi sappiamo
È bellissimo vorrei continuare tutto il
giorno
[Musica]
Bohemian Rhapsody
il titolo
auto blu
esatto
[Musica]
amore
e Rossella È vero
Allora ok Si può vedere si possono
vederlo
ratatouija
non c'è non ci sono i topi in questo
film proprio non ci sono i topi Ti giuro
Oh
Minchia ma che era da due siamo usciti
[Risate]
No no allora allora no cioè scusami eh
le le sue raccomandazioni Io non vorrei
dire ma è ehm allora è perché pensavo
rischiasse subito dove posso
assolutamente prenotarmi Io vabbè Eh lo
ricompro Peccato perché però funziona
ancora se schiacciamo solo questo sono
in tutto questo
[Musica]
Alleluia In che film compare
i topi comunque
perché ci viene sempre in mente
io vado avanti
Califano
ha detto giusto io Grazie ultima
l'ultima qua ci si gioca tutto
giochiamoci tutto
Dai vai senti vai vai vai
[Musica]
va bene che dire il miglior video del
mese Però sono molto contrariato perché
non c'è stata la canzone ce la puoi fare
per favore no L'idea di come faccio
qualsiasi canzone francese vai
[Musica]
questo è stato un video Incredibile
Spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
grazie Google
che sta facendo la colonna sonora
dell'auto
il becco il copyright
e il telecomandino e noi ci vediamo ad
un prossimo video Grazie ancora ragazzi
iscrivetevi al canale dei ragazzi
lasciate in descrizione e
noi ci vediamo
[Musica]
dai la nonna ragazzi